okay next speaker is lynch he's speaking
about
kernels
okay
yeah
uh hello everybody um today i'm going to
talk about uh deep neural tendon kernel
and the laplace kernel have the same
rkhs
and another project
okay uh this is the word population i
clear 21.
so let's review let's have a quick
review of what's uh what's our kernel uh
k from e times e to r is a kernel if it
is symmetric
and the gram matrix uh is positive
semi-definite for
any x1 through xn
and for each kernel we have associated
reproducing kernel cuber space and let's
have also have a quick review
an rkhs on e is a hubert space
with a function
k
from e times e to r which is called the
reproducing kernel and it must enjoy the
reproducing property
first we require that k sub x a k sub x
uh it is k
com dot comma x it must be in the huber
space
and uh the reputation property is that
for any function in the hubert space
f of x must be equal to
the inner product between f and k sub x
and there is a
theorem for any kernel k
there is this uh uniquely determined
rkhs um denoted by h sub k of e
admitting that reproducing kernel k on e
okay
and uh what's a neural tangent kernel
people found that a gradient flow or
normally initialized fully connected
infinitely wide neural network is
equivalent to kernel regression
with respect to the ntk
and
we use n k n sub k to denote the k plus
one layer uh rayleigh ntk
uh on the unit on the unisphere
and
nk can be uh
is given by the following recursive
relation
so we relate n k to
some function kappa 0 kappa 1 and n k
minus 1
where kappa 0 and capital one are two
functions
and capital one to the k is the case
iterate of kappa 1.
okay
my first result is
the rkhs of the reload ntk is
actually equal to the rkhs of the
laplace kernel
if they are viewed as a sets
um
so to be precise with that
h of love and h
sub nk with rkhs associated with the
laplace kernel which is e to the
minus c
norm of x minus y
and ntk
on the unit sphere then the two spaces
include the same set of functions
note that this equation holds no matter
how many layers you have so even if you
have many layers but uh
the rk edges of the neural tension
kernel a regular ntk will not grow
with more layers and since an rkh has
characterizes the expressive power of a
kernel to some extent uh this is
actually a an active result for the
kernel regime of neural nets
uh proof technique um so i analyzed the
decay rate of the power series
coefficients around zero
of the kernels using complex analysis
and the decay rate is determined by the
asymptotic order around the closest
singularities
okay
and
the second result
in the second result a second result is
about smoothness and the size of rkhs
here i consider the exponential power
kernel which is given by exponential to
the
minus the null of x minus y to the gamma
over sigma
and i consider the exponential power
kernel on the unisphere and the entire
space
and note that the explanation power
kernel is the generalization of the
laplace kernel if gamma equals one
and here i have an illustration of the
kernel for different gamma values we can
see that if gamma is one which is the
blue curve
and if gamma is one half it is the
red curve and if if gamma is one third
it is the green curve we can see that if
gamma is smaller than the current is
more known smooth
and the theorem tells us that
if we have a smaller gamma then the rkhs
is actually larger no matter you are on
the entire space or on a unisphere
and technique
um so we want to prove the inclusion of
rkhs
we only need suffices to prove that the
difference of the two kernels is policy
definite
and we can prove this using
inverse laplace transfer which can be
obtained by our quantum integration
okay so these are the two main results
of my first project here
and the second one the second one is
about
feature engineering uh it was population
esa 21.
okay
so
um
let me show the main results first
let p0 and p1 be two distributions on
the product space of v1 through vm
and a is a subset of
one to n
and we write the partial product space v
capital a is the you know the product of
v a for a in capital a
and we denote the marginal distribution
of v sub capital a by
uh p0 and p1a
and the first result is the hardest
result
i showed that there is no end to the one
over poly log log n approximation
algorithm for the fully maximization
problem unless the exponential time
hypothesis fails
the exponential time hypothesis says
that three sets cannot be solved in
sub-exponential time in the worst case
and the maximization problem which is
hard is the following
we want to maximize over all
size k subset of n
and we want to maximize the total
variation distance between
p1a times p0a and p0a times p1a
this is hard without any assumption it
is hard in general
but
if p0 and p1 are factorizable that means
they can be expressed as product of
marginal distributions on each vi then
this function is monotone and submodular
uh submodular means um v
fa plus fb is greater than f
a intersection a intersection b plus f
a union b
then there is this uh a polynomial time
one minus one of e approximation
algorithm
so this is the you know tradability
results however you may wonder why do we
need to care about this function so
why do we need to why we are interested
in this this kind of function
well
let me show you why we care about that
it actually rises in
when we solve a future selection problem
and we believe that this result can be
of independent interest to like
statistics statisticians
okay we consider a classification
classification task and we are given n
categorical features and a binary label
column
we use
x i to denote the value of the i's
feature column
and the c be the binary label
v i is the vocabulary
then we model data set as a distribution
so that means
x1 3xn
comma c follows the distribution d
let's see this example
in this example we have two feature
columns which is country and the
language and we have a label
binary label
and
the data is very small it only has two
rows
the first is scotland english and second
row is mexico in spanish
then
x1 x2c followed distribution it is
scotland english one was probably one
half and it is mexico spanish zero was
probably one half
and the vocabulary of the first feature
column is scotland in mexico and the
vocabulary of the second column is
english and spanish
and
we want to select a subset of future
columns
and we need to quantify how good
the selective
feature colors are right
so let's input let's consider very
simple model here we can see the score
function sigma that assigns a score in
zero and one to each value
of the
selective future columns
for example if a the selective feature
column only contains the country future
in the previous example
and we we can assign scotland
we can assign one-third to score plan
and assign one-half to mexico
then given
a threshold between
yeah thank you
given threshold between 0 and 1 we
predict 1 if sigma is greater than the
threshold and predicts 0 otherwise then
we can get a positive and true and
quality true and false positive rate
then we vary tau from zero to one we get
a curve the auc the area under the curve
measure is the area under this curve in
measure the performance of sigma
and because this measure depends on the
selection of sigma
we can see that the optimal auc which is
auc of the optimal score function
and we find that
auc is actually equal to a linear
function
of the total variation distance
here we just consider then our results
give the following
so
there there is no
approximation algorithm
for
uh for for this uh
uh maximization problem
unless the um exponential time
hypothesis fails
and under the naive bayes assumption
there is a polynomial time one minus one
one over e approximation to this uh
maximization problem so
this is our uh the main result of our my
second project here
yeah thank you so much
okay